But like, just to be safe, and I don't want to get famine in trouble, I'll try to censor myself.
But yeah, it's really great to see all of you guys.
I am quite hyped up in caffeine right now.
Because it's going to be a very long day.
If you guys didn't know my schedule, it was really like...
It was really like, I had a 10 a.m.
tech check, and then obviously paddle, which is right now.
And then right after this panel ends, I have to go straight to Twitch to stream the Mama Rylos Early Access.
Because it starts exactly at 2.
And then right after that, I have to tech check for the meet and greet.
And then right after that, it's the meet and greet.
So it's a very long day for me.
Go, go get it!
And then the worst part was that my dog, Dad, Doki Amber Doge, yes, for those who don't know, my dog's name is Dad, because his name is also Doki.
Yes, I named him after myself because I'm an egomaniac.
So I call him Dad for Doki Amber Doge, just to differentiate between Doki Bird and Doki Doge.
But anyway, this piece of shit was at 5 in the morning, and it continued to wake me up every hour.
So it was like 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, and I'm like, what do you want?
And then, so, I was like, please, because, like, I think he realized that, like, the last time he gave up, but then now, I think it's because he's getting better now, because he was recovering from surgery a month ago.
So, like, every day he gets stronger, and then every day he's realizing, wait, you're the bitch.
Like, so, he's like, every day he's like, this is it, I know, I know you will listen to me eventually.
And he was right, because at 9 in the morning, I eventually got up, because I was like, I can't.
He's, every hour, you're just gonna wake me up, I will do your walkies, feed you, and then I know I can't sleep anywhere, because I have to do the tech check at 10 in the morning.
So, that's why I'm, like, super hyped up on caffeine right now, because I need it to survive the rest of the day.
But, yes, anyway, I know you guys are here to ask me questions, so I guess it's time to bring you guys in.
So, I believe you can start lining up if you want to, and let's get the Q&A started.
I'm looking forward to talking to you guys.
Can you hold this?
Also, yeah, for those who don't know, I did shadow drop the FNAF 3D cover, so you guys want to see.
And so many people were like, why did she upload the 3D cover out of nowhere?
Because I literally got it this morning, and I was like, why not?
It was like, I was like, yeah, might as well put it up.
Okay, question, question.
Hi, Donkey.
Long time to be here.
My question is, will you ever use Doki Field again?
Doki Field?
Okay, the reason why I don't use, I use him once.
Like I say him.
I use Doki Field once.
It's because it is a lot of work to set up.
Because that skin suit is on an entirely different program.
And it's like, I don't know, I don't even remember what program it was, but it was on an entirely different program.
And it doesn't use, like, phone, it uses, like, a webcam.
And I was like, I can't, because the thing is, my webcam cable is too short.
Because my monitor is too high.
So, like, it cannot reach the top of the monitor.
So, I had to, like, MacGyver my way to put the webcam somewhere.
So, like, I really had to stack books and stuff just to place the webcam and just to make it work.
And so, like, after that, I just got really lazy.
Because I was like, well, I can't be bothered stacking stuff again.
But, like, maybe whenever I get not lazy, so, like, maybe next year, when I'm not as lazy.
But I would love to use that skin suit again in the future.
Like I said, it's mostly because of my own laziness.
Because, like, usually when I start streaming, I prep.
I think you guys all know, I set up, like, five minutes before I stream.
And so, so, it's like, maybe when I don't do that, I can set up Doke Field again.
But, yeah, I hope that answers your question.
Thank you.
Good luck with the game later.
Oh, thank you.
Hello, hello.
Hello, Doki.
So, my question is, do you plan to do another WrestleTuber this year?
Oh, my gosh.
I know a lot of people have asked me that.
Yes, I am planning on doing it again this year.
The reason why, I've not planned it at all, so you don't expect it soon.
But, I've been very, very busy this year in general.
So, I haven't had the time to actually plan it through.
And that's why, like, it's been, like, on a hiatus for now.
I mean, it will come back eventually this year.
Because, like, I'm not going to, like, make you guys wait until, like, next year or anything.
But, like, for now, like, it's still, like, in hibernation.
And to, like, all the other stuff that I have going on.
There's so many things going on behind the scenes.
Like, that's why I'm, like, all over the place.
I mean, like, I haven't had a new outfit in more than a year now, guys.
So, why don't you think about that?
So, I have a lot of other stuff lined up.
So, that's why the WrestleTuber thing has been on hiatus for now.
But it will come back this year.
Just not in the next, like, couple of months.
Or, like, two or three months, maybe.
All right.
Thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
Hey.
Sorry, I forgot my words for a moment.
What are some general lives goals that you have before starting a stream?
Like, can you repeat that?
What are some general lives goals that you have before you start a stream?
One of my general life goals before I start, before I became a streamer?
No, like, generalize with an I-Z-E.
Wait.
Sorry, I'm a little slow right now.
The screen is, like, not working 3D.
No worries.
Generalize?
Lize?
Generalized.
Like, generalized.
Just general.
General.
Why am I so confused?
I can't, I can't figure out what you said.
General what?
Generalized.
Wait.
Can my, can my staff pick up what the general what?
Oh, my God.
I can't, for some reason, I don't know why I can't comprehend it.
General what?
No, that's Jim Dean on the desk, bro.
That's Jim Dean on the desk.
Wait, General, no one's cutting in and out.
I can't hear it.
Wait, spell it out.
G-E-N-E-R-A-L-I-Z-A-D.
General.
Gen-E-I-D.
Generalized.
Oh, generalized.
What are some generalized goals that you have before starting the stream?
Ah, okay.
I don't know why I couldn't understand that question for the longest time.
I told you guys, today I'm really slow today.
My mind has not been okay.
Waking up at five in the morning is not great for me.
Who would have thought?
Okay, my generalized goals.
Okay, so before I start streaming, I actually just go in head empty.
Like, I go in and be like, alright, gotta stream this today.
And then I just go in.
Whatever happens, happens.
Like, I don't have a set plan when I stream.
It's just mostly... I think that's why people are like, oh, we can never...
Like, you don't know what to expect in a dealkeeper's stream.
That's correct, because I don't know what to expect either.
So I go in and just say whatever is in my mind, like, just right off the bat.
But I do try to censor myself, because I was like, YouTube terms of services.
So I just make sure I don't breach any TOS lining there.
And then, you know, so like, but I do...
Like, I just literally just be like, something, some random ass thought pops up in my head, and then I just say it.
But yeah, like, as long as you Dragoons have a good time, enjoy yourself, and I have fun, that's all that matters to me.
So yeah, that's really it.
There's really no goals I set up for myself.
I just go straight in.
I think it's because I've been doing this for so long, that like, for me, it's just like...
I don't want to say autopilot, because like, I still am aware of what I'm doing.
But like, it's just more self-experience-wise, because you do it so often.
Like, it's just, you turn on the stream, and then you just go.
Like, that's it.
You just go until you're tired, or you finish the game, or like, something incredibly frustrating happens that you crash out, and then you just leave.
Like, that's really it.
But yes, thank you for the question.
I'm sorry, I don't know why I forgot what generalize means.
No worries.
Just to preface this question, you know what general...
Sorry.
You know what consultation work is, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I know my words, guys.
English is my first language, don't worry.
So, um...
As a pro gamer, and as a community figure, if a game studio ever approached you for general consultation work, would you ever consider doing it?
Well, if I get paid.
Like...
I was like...
I was saying this, I don't have a lot of time.
So, it's worse though, like...
It's really hard to, like, if someone wants, like, you know...
I guess, like, want me to do it for free.
Um, it's most likely no, because I don't have a lot of time in general.
Um, and, um...
So, like, my schedule...
Like, you said, like, you know, like, today, it's like...
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom.
And so, it's more likely that I will do it, if it's like, you know, it's like a paid work type of deal.
So, um...
I mean, it's very interesting.
But like I said, like, there's not...
I don't really have a lot of free time these days.
Especially, like, um...
There's a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes in general for me.
So, I would love to have the opportunity.
But like I said, I don't...
I can't really do it for free type deal.
Uh, so, but yeah.
Thank you for the question.
Yeah.
Uh, just a quick addendum.
Uh, the...
Yeah, the exposure, like, say, from, like, Marvel Rivals or Apex.
What do you consider?
For Marvel Rivals or Apex?
Yeah, we're approaching.
If they want my consultation on their game...
Um, first off, why are they asking my opinion on how to...
Like, I feel like...
Especially if I...
If I...
Okay, that's what scares me the most.
Cause it's like, if I give the wrong ideas on how to change a character...
I am gonna be like...
Like, people would send in hate crowds at me.
Because people would be like, How dare you ruin Jeff?
Or...
Like, how dare you break this game for us?
Why are they asking random VTubers on how to balance...
This game?
Who is she?
Like...
I saw, like, when they announced the people who were doing the early access...
I saw some people on the...
Comment section...
Be like...
Why are you letting these streamers play the game?
Like, play your game early access!
I was like, whoa, what?
And then...
Sprinkled in would be like...
People would be like...
You broke Jeff!
Fix Jeff!
And then...
Little do they know...
Okay, I'm gonna give you guys a little spoiler.
A little, like...
Two hour...
Like, one hour spoiler before I stream it.
Jeff is like...
Broken...
But not for the reasons the general crowd thinks he's broken.
They think they destroyed Jeff as in he's unplayable right now.
But Jeff right now is incredibly broken.
Because I was testing it last night.
And...
It was crazy.
Because, like...
Okay, for those who speak Marvel Rivals.
I'm sorry for those who don't speak Marvel Rivals.
And be like...
What the heck is she talking about?
But...
Um...
I figured out...
That, like...
When you...
In the Jeff vault, you eat somebody.
And then...
Obviously, the person takes damage in the Jeff vault.
But then when the storm picks you up...
The storm vault also kills the person in the Jeff vault.
So I was like...
Oh my god!
And then he's just dead.
You're just dead.
Like...
And then you can't kill Jeff because he's in the storm vault.
And she has 800 HP.
Um...
But you'll find that out in, like, 30 minutes.
Like...
He's gonna be, like, really broken for in 2...
Season 2.5.
And everybody's gonna play him.
Because I found out how broken he is.
Anyway...
Sorry.
But, like...
If I was...
If they asked me about the...
What it do for changes...
I'd be like...
I don't know...
Make Luna...
Like...
Make Luna Snow have, like...
700 HP or something.
I don't know.
So...
Die won't kill her.
And then everyone's gonna hate me.
So, yeah.
No, I don't know why they'll ask me for my opinion.
Thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
Hello.
I would have a curious question.
Um...
Are you open to collaborating with, like...
Smaller, on-the-rise...
YouTubers or streamers?
Or people that...
Are trying to get...
Trying to get more successful?
No?
Is that a curiosity?
Well, I wouldn't say I would randomly collab with people.
I would collab with people that I know and feel familiar with.
Um...
Because, like, you know, there's a lot of people in the VTuber community.
And, like, um...
I also want to know, like, if we have chemistry or if there are, like, people that...
Um...
That I would vibe with.
It's more so vibes for me.
Um...
Because I don't randomly just, like, collaborate...
Like, uh...
Right now, like, in my...
You guys might notice I haven't done a lot of collaboration recently.
But also it's because I've been, like, very busy with all the stuff that's going...
Coming up.
And a lot of the collaborations that I do is mostly me reaching out to people in general.
And then it's me thinking, like, what do my...
What do Dragoons want to see?
And, like, what kind of, like, connections or collaborations they want me to have?
So it's more so, like, that when I organize collabs.
It's more like, what do Dragoons want to see?
Who do they want me to interact with?
Do I think that this person I'm going to be interacting with have, like, good chemistry with me?
Because, you know, that's the scary part about collaborating with someone you don't know.
Um...
or you never talked to before in the past, is that you might not have a very good collab, because it might be very awkward.
Because that's always how things go sometimes.
Well, not always, but that's a little underlying fear for me.
Especially when I do these... Right now, I have the thing with other streamers, and a lot of these streamers, I have never interacted with before.
So it's always such an underlying fear for me, because I'm like, oh, I've never talked to these people before.
So it's very scary for me, and I get very anxious and stuff like that, especially when it's a huge group.
I don't mind if it's a group setting, more so, because then maybe I have someone that I do know in there, and then someone I don't know.
But it's not for a collab, it's not like... I pick who I want to, based off of if I think that we have good chemistry in the end.
Like, if I would vibe with this person.
So it's not like, oh, I don't...
I have collabed with smaller VTubers or smaller content creators, but it's more so like I know that...
It's like people that I know that we would have good chemistry with, or good back and forth with in general.
So yeah, it's just that, really.
It's not like I don't just randomly be like, you, collab with me.
I also look into like, how we would interact.
Like, maybe.
How it would go.
Okay, thank you again.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, no problem.
Cool.
Hi, Doki.
My name's Corey.
So, uh, with, uh, Maid, Minthe, and being really good at singing and dancing, do you see yourself want to continue improving singing and your dancing?
Um, dancing is so hard, man.
I think, I remember.
Okay, like, Minthe, she's been doing this for years.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Like, she's been like dancing even before she was a VTuber.
And it's like, I, when I saw her dance in real life, um, like during a concert, it was like, it's crazy.
I was like, how do you do all that stuff with your body?
Like, how do you, how does it move like that?
Like, and then, like, I had to do, like, I don't remember how long I did dance classes for, but like, it was so hard.
It was so, so hard.
I remember I was just like, I don't know, I just know I was very, very tired.
Um, and my dances weren't even that difficult, too.
Like, compared to what she did.
Um, but like, ah, man.
Like, if I have to do, like, a concert again, or like anything related to dancing, I will have to do dance classes.
But I know that dancing, I definitely won't be doing it a lot.
It's only when I'm like, it's like a mandatory thing, you know?
Where it's like, oh, you have a concert soon, you gotta do choreo.
And I was like, alright, dance classes, here I come!
Singing-wise, ah, I've always, I wish I can, I wish I can sing.
Sometimes.
Cause like, um, singing is very, like for me, I'm not a natural singer.
Because I didn't grow up singing.
Um, instead I spent my days studying.
Like, uh, doing what my parents wanted me to do.
Locked up in their room and studied.
Um, and so like, I haven't had singing lessons in a long, long time.
It's more so like, time-wise too, I just don't have time.
And I do like, I would love to do, do more singing stuff.
Um, but it's also like, my biggest issue was that, I think you guys all know, I had voice, like, not voice issues, but like, I was sick for a long time.
I mean, I got sick for like, like continuously for a year.
So it was like, for those who don't remember, it's like, last year, it's like, I got sick.
And then for like, two months or some shit, and I was like, copying everything.
And then I got better.
And then I got sick again.
And then I went to Japan, and I got sick.
And then I got better.
And then like, I got sick again.
And now I'm here.
I'm better now.
Um, so, my throat has not been okay for a year.
Um, so, um, let's hope I don't get sick again.
Because this is the, I feel like this is the longest I've been like, this is the longest I could breathe through my nose.
So, um, I do want to do more singing in the future, and like, maybe release more song covers.
And I do have like, some original songs in the works.
I just haven't recorded for them.
Because I had like, an original song finished.
Like, they made the lyrics and everything.
It was all finished.
It just needed me to record.
And then it's literally been sitting in the back corner for half a year.
Because I was not okay for half a year.
Like, I couldn't.
My throat was not okay for half a year.
So they've been like, waiting for me to record for the longest time.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
I just can't record.
Um, but whatever.
I would like to do it more in the future.
Thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
What's up, Doki?
What's up?
Eh!
That's not my question.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I was gonna say, leave.
Fine, jeez.
Okay.
Well, speaking of Marvel rivals, I'm a big fan of that.
So it's important that I get your opinion on this.
Mm-hmm.
What are your opinions on the balance changes?
And on top of that, do you think we should nerf Adam Warlock's movement?
Oh.
Oh my god.
You wanna...
You wanna break his legs again?
Like...
Yeah!
Screw that guy!
The guy's been through some...
Bored again!
Yeah, no, I don't want that.
You wanna break his legs.
Um, he had one...
He had half a season to walk again.
And you already wanna break his legs.
Okay.
Well, um, you guys didn't know.
Um, Hawkeye can shoot through walls now, so...
So...
I didn't know about that.
What?
I...
You're like, oh...
You're gonna find out in, like, 30 minutes.
Um, I don't know if that was in the patch notes, but I was testing it out, and Hawkeye was literally...
I was like, you know...
Oh yeah, and the further you are, the more damage it does, and there's no...
There's no really falloff for his, like, freeze in air or whatever, because of this new Luna-Snow team-up.
But yeah, I literally can shoot...
You can shoot through multiple walls, too, by the way.
So, there's that.
Yeah, Hawkeye is really scary now.
Um...
Other than that, well...
I don't know.
It feels like...
It feels like it's gonna be very interesting, the new season.
Season 2.5.
Ultron was really fun when I was testing Ultron up.
It was really fun.
But, like, every DPS player is gonna try and play him.
Um...
Because he doesn't...
His left click is heal.
It's not heal.
It's damage.
It's only damage.
His...
His aiming mechanic is all damage.
And his only heal is, like, an ability.
So...
So, it was very interesting to play.
By the way, guys.
I finally finded my descent key on flying characters.
For those who don't know, I never had the ability to go down when I play flying characters.
Because I never needed to because I placed the point.
So, what I do when I play flying characters is that I look down.
So...
Obviously, that's not useful.
So, I have to finally find a key to actually go down when I play Ultron.
I'm so proud of you.
When I play Ultron.
Um...
Uh...
But, yeah.
That's what I think about the current balance changes so far.
Um...
It's just very interesting.
I don't know if it'll make the game fun or make the game worse.
But as long as it kills dive, I'm happy.
Like, that's all I care about.
Thank you, Doki.
That was very informative.
Yeah, no problem.
You have a good one, alright?
Yeah, you too.
Howdy, Doki.
Hope you're doing good.
Howdy.
I got a glow stick in your color.
And...
Wow!
It has a mint inside of it.
That's, uh...
Ooh!
Yeah.
And that does lead into the question.
Um...
I would dare say that mint is your best friend.
So, might as well ask a fun one.
What would you say is your favorite memory with Mint Fantome, either on stream or in real life?
Uh...
That's really difficult because, like, we've done so much stuff together.
So...
I guess, like...
Uh...
Oh, man.
That's so difficult.
We've done so many things together.
But favorite memory so far...
Oh, my gosh.
Uh...
Oh, I'm sorry.
There's so many!
There's so many fun memories we've had together.
So it's, like, really difficult.
Like, um...
I guess, like...
If I say recent...
I think, like, every time I hang out with Mint, it's, like, a fun time.
So, like...
That's why it's, like, really difficult to say what's, like, my favorite memory.
Like, the Visage thing was really fun when we did that collab together.
Um...
And then, you know, when we did, like, um...
When we hanged out in Japan, that was fun.
When we did the concert together, that was also really, really fun.
Um...
Like, so it's so difficult to just be, like, oh, pinpoint your favorite memory.
Because, like, every time I hang out with her, it's just been a good time.
So, uh...
It's very difficult.
Okay.
I mean, as long as you're having fun with her, I got a good answer.
All right.
Cool.
Thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
Uh, hi, yeah.
I just wanted to ask a hypothetical question.
So, I know you a little bit more from your Apex Legends scene, so this may pertain more towards those players.
But, I just wanted to ask, hypothetically, if a pro player, let's say, maybe, oh, I don't know, IPN or Nocturnal, if they got bitten by a snake in, uh, very precarious positions, would you be willing to suck the poison out of them in order to save their lives?
Unfortunately, I didn't mean to suck them so clearly why don't they suck each other off, why don't they suck each other off, so why don't they suck each other off?
Aww.
There are several there, so like, well, they're just to help each other out, so they save both, both of their lives... and they don't have to owe each other a favor, because, you know, You know, they both save each other's lives.
So it's like a dumb deal.
And I can be in the corner watching again.
Hi.
Hey Adoki, my name is Duke.
Hey.
How you doing?
That's all my question.
Doing great.
What got you into FPS games like Apex Survivals?
Um, well, I just, I'm just a very competitive person in general.
I don't remember talking about this before, but like, basically, like, my very first shooter game was Splatoon.
And like, the adrenaline from Splatoon.
No, I think Splatoon is my most toxic era ever.
Because like, the reason being is that you can't talk to anyone.
You can't communicate with anything.
All you can say is, woohoo, and woo me.
Like, but that doesn't convey how you feel when your teammate messes up.
Like, like, what do you say?
You say, woo me.
But like, in your mind, inside of you, you're like, I hate you.
Like, you're a child too.
And you're like, woo me.
So it's like, I think, like, Splatoon cultivated the toxicity inside me.
I have slammed my controller before.
Like, actually, like, I wouldn't throw it on a ground.
There would be a box there.
And I would like, slam, I would throw my controller in a box.
So I wouldn't break my controller.
But I have got really toxic playing Splatoon.
But anyway, and then it was, like, Splatoon.
And then, you know, my friends would be like, oh, Overwatch.
Try Overwatch.
And then that's where I got into FPS gaming.
And it's basically just, like, the competitive nature of everything.
I've just, like, seen numbers go up.
And just, like, I want to be, like, you know, the best player and stuff like that.
It's just the adrenaline rush of, like, being good at a video game.
And, like, you know, trying to aim for a goal.
You know, like, oh, top 500 or something.
It's just such an adrenaline rush, just, like, getting there and everything.
And it's, like, an addiction.
Because you're, like, one more, you know.
One more game.
And then it'll be gone.
And then you're, like, you can't end on a loss, you know.
It's, like, an addiction.
Yeah, like, that's what, like, FPS does.
Like, shooter games and FPS does to me.
And that's why, like, I got really into it.
Like, I like how it makes it sound very, like, unhealthy.
Very unhealthy and not good for you.
But, like, that's what makes, like, shooter games, FPS competitive games, like, really fun for me in general.
Just because I love the rank experience.
I remember when Marvel Rivals first came out and I just did quick play.
And I was like, this game is not that fun.
Because I was just doing quick play.
Like, for the beta.
Because beta didn't have rank yet.
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
I don't seem to feel like it's going to be a game that I'm going to enjoy.
But, because I was just playing quick play.
And then rank came out.
And now look at me.
I have a problem.
I...
So, yeah, I hope that answers your question.
Yeah, no, I suck at FPS games.
I'm going to bet the games.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, no problem.
Hello.
Hey.
Long time here.
First time asker.
So I just got a really serious question for you.
Uh-huh.
How well did you sleep last night after the Simpsons hit the run stream?
Terribly.
Yeah.
Never going to touch your car again.
Terribly because, like, okay, right after...
You know, I thought I would be like, yay, it's over, I can have a good night's today.
But after, I got a message being like, make sure to download the game engine for the early access before tomorrow.
And I was like, aw, shit.
And then because of that, I had to test everything out.
And then I started going through everything.
So then I went to bed at, not really late, I went to bed at midnight or something.
So there was that.
And then, you know, this beautiful dog of mine started being like, feed me at five in the morning.
Which is weird because we're not off schedule.
Like, he's trying to make his own schedule right now.
Thinking I don't know what time it is.
So, he's like, maybe if I try and trick her and make her feed me early, then I can eat food earlier.
But I don't think he understands that I have a clock.
My phone tells me the time.
But anyway, he woke me up several times.
So, like, I am not okay.
Just can't catch a break, huh?
Well, he's got little rivals next.
Yay!
Hi there, Doki.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah, nice to meet you, too.
Alright, this question is going to touch on your Three Kingdoms brain rod.
Are you ready?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, if you were a faction leader in the Three Kingdoms, who would be your five Tiger Generals and your main concubine?
The main concubine?
Okay.
Okay, one of them will be Zhugok Lun, and then he's going to be the concubine.
I know he can do it.
And then, the second one...
Well, I don't want Simai because he'll just kill me in the end.
Like, he'll backstack me in the end.
And it's like, I don't think that's cool.
Just take over when you're dead.
It's fine.
I don't think... I don't know.
He's going to rename the kingdom.
It'll be like, yay, the Joki Dynasty.
And then he's going to kill me.
He's like, okay, but what if it's the Jin Dynasty?
So I don't like that.
So no Simai, even though he's like a really great strategist.
But like...
And then the four other ones.
And then Guanyin because he's literally the god of war.
Like, why would I say no to a god of war?
And then Zhang Liao because he's loyal as hell, too.
And he's very strong because he has beat my ass several times.
Daoyin because he's also loyal as hell, too.
And like, he is loved by... he's loved by Dynasty Warriors, so he'll get everything.
And that means I'll get everything.
And then the fifth one.
Ooh, that's difficult.
That's very difficult because I got all the good ones now.
I get Shao Jun because he's hot.
Yeah!
No!
Eyepatch or no eyepatch?
Eyepatch.
That makes him hotter.
It's the eyepatch.
We all know.
Even if you're straight, you know he's pretty hot.
Okay, cool.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, the eyepatch stays on.
We're going to do a group shot at the end.
Hello!
This is going to be a loud question, okay?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, sure.
Well, sorry, guys.
Yeah, you might.
One question for my noodle arm dosher.
So if you could keep only one model between Kroki and Doe Kitty, which one would it be in the model?
Wait, if I could what?
Only keep one model between Kroki...
Oh, if I could keep one model?
Oh, Kroki for sure.
Yeah, that's funny.
For sure.
I would send Doe Kitty to the...
Like, Doe Kitty is your favorite.
It's the people's favorite.
I would send Doe Kitty to the farm with no hesitation.
Keep Kroki.
Kroki...
I think Kroki is basically...
If I was a tomato, Kroki would be, like, actually my inner self.
Like, I don't know.
I just fit...
I don't know why, but my voice just fits so well with Kroki.
Like, if I could just be an animal instead of, like, an anime girl, I would be a Kroki the entire time.
But if people be like, that's weird.
And I'm like, I'm not a furry.
I don't want to O.C.
a crown.
So then that's why I'm an anime girl.
Thank you.
All right.
No problem.
Junkie, do you have any last messages for them?
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
I already forgot you said this was the last question.
I was going to be like, wait, what?
But thank you, everybody, for coming to my panel.
So it truly is a great honor to be Fatima's first YouTuber guest of honor.
And it's always great to talk to all my dragoons here.
Because it's like, you guys are real, you know?
It's like, oh, my God, you're actually here.
And, like, you're not, like, bots or something.
You're real people.
Oh, my gosh.
And I always love doing these conventions and talking to all you guys.
It's like, you know, it's a little private, like, back to the honor chatting stream with you guys.
So it's such a fun experience.
And that's why I do all these conventions and go around the world, meeting my dragoons.
Because it's always a great experience.
So thank you, everybody, for coming to my panel.